attention this next story will help you
save some money this Thanksgiving our
consumer savings expert has simple
grocery hacks to help stretch your
dollars
Thanksgiving is causing concern for
Americans as grocery prices for the
feast turkey eggs butter and flour
continue to soar ahead of the holiday
you can lower that grocery bill by
focusing on what your family enjoys most
skip the rest also seek less expensive
substitutes maybe a swap using sweet
potatoes which haven't seen the same
increase in prices or there are even
some different alternative sauces that
you can use instead of cranberries right
you can create maybe an apple chutney
pomegranate sauce and just give it a fun
twist this year to help you save money
consumer savings expert Andrea warrock
says shop your pantry first for hidden
ingredients that you could use
breadcrumbs sauces marinades baking
supplies and spices or herbs for box
canned or frozen food opt for the store
brands you're going to save 30 percent
avoid the bakery section they have some
of the highest markups pre-made pies and
cookies they are marked up over 300
percent now if you don't want to make
everything from scratch you can still
save by buying pre-made cake mixes or
cookie mixes or pie crust mixes in the
boxed section and avoid impulse
purchases at the store by creating a
list and placing your orders online go
to couponfollow.com they had deals like
20 off plus free delivery at vons.com 15
off at Kroger plus free delivery a deal
for 10 off at instacart
and keep in mind friends and family they
love contributing so don't take all the
cooking or costs on yourself ask your
guests to bring a favorite side dish
dessert or beverage